with skincare from fashion to skin care
that is a top priority especially here
in vegas so katya and ashton from pearl
skin studio are here to help us maintain
or achieve it first and then maintain it
right yes definitely we live in las
vegas we all need facials because it's
so dry
and
your concern is
aging
if you're concerned about your pores
texture of your skin pigmentation
facials are the perfect thing for you
okay and katya who can get a facial
there's no age limit there's no none of
that so who can actually get a facial
out no men women teenagers you know
anybody older younger anyone because
skin is the largest organ and you need
to take care of it in order to look
healthy absolutely absolutely so ashton
you're an esthetician there at
pearl skin studio so what kind of
facials do you guys offer and what's on
the table for us pretty much everything
we can kind of troubleshoot whatever you
have we have teen facials we have body
treatments um we have different
protocols one that is our most popular
right now is going to be the hydrafacial
i love a good hydration it's so amazing
i'm sure you know it's going to be a
machine facial it's going to be
hydrating exfoliating you're immediately
going to get a glow and it's going to be
so claritive it's amazing
wow and you said body treatments too
what kind of body treatments yes we can
do full body scrubs we do have our
pearls glow as well that's going to be a
facial and back treatment hybrid so you
get a scrub you get a massage it's
amazing as well now you guys are the
only studio in town in town that do that
one right we do talk about that
okay well i actually have the poultice
right here that we will use in your
treatment right there there we go so
what it's going to be is basically an
herbal
pouch that's going to get really hot as
well
so it is going to mimic the feeling of
hot stones and it's also going to be
detoxifying for the skin you get that it
smells amazing so it's not only going to
be something that's very relaxing very
luxurious feeling we're going to take
care of a lot of our skin as well
and just to let you know it's disposable
and you get to take it home
[Laughter]
now you are the owner just give us a
brief description of your studio and why
people should come by well originally i
thought that it's going to be skin
studio that's why it's called pro skin
studio right but now it's full service
salon i never expect it to grow that big
so this particular treatment pros glow
with the back treatment i developed
because i've been in the industry for so
long and i know that people don't don't
take care of their back and they want to
come to relax and they want to see
results so this is the treatment to get
thank you well in vegas we need full
body treatments yeah okay because we're
driving very well
thank you ladies so much thank you to
pearlskin studio for sponsoring this
segment so many great special offers as
we just mentioned or begin to mention
purchase a signature hydrafacial or
pearls glow membership mention las vegas
now and receive a free
janmarini
bioglycolic did i say that right face
cleanser that's normally 45 value okay
it's also twenty percent off all
additional skin care services and
treatments and retail purchases so for
more information just head to
pearlskinstudio.com that was great thank
you lady